by for me uh we're just getting in some
breaking news right now uh and I want to
head right to the Pentagon Rich Edson is
standing by it seems that in a strike
that had been talked about uh may be
materializing now in the Middle East to
go back at the hooty Rebels for some of
those attacks is that right Rich that's
right Brett we're just getting early
details of this right now according to
two US officials uh they're saying that
there have been joint us UK air strikes
against houie targets in Yemen remember
we talked about this just about 50
minutes ago on the show there have been
multiple attacks 28 some attacks on
shipping lanes from hooti Rebels a
massive attack on Tuesday that the US
and UK had to repel uh the chairman of
the Joint Chiefs of of of Staff talked
to his British counterpart yesterday uh
and now some 24 hours later we've got
news of these attacks we're still trying
to figure out how many targets what kind
of targets but we do know joint us UK
attacks on houie Targets in Yemen
uh either ongoing right now or just
finishing up Brett yeah both US military
uh and British military beginning these
bombing sites uh inside Yemen massive
retaliatory strikes is how it's being
described uh by both Nations uh now this
is after these Red Sea strikes as also
uh more than 130 strikes on US troops
throughout the region not only from the
hooes but other Iranian backed proxies
that's right Brett this is all Iran
behind things here you've got the
Iranians backing the houthis you've got
the Iranians backing proxy groups uh in
Iraq and Syria some 130 strikes against
us positions in those countries just
since the middle of October and then on
top of all that earlier today you had
Iran seizing Iran directly the Iranian
Navy directly seizing an oil tanker uh
in the Middle East so Iran behind all of
these different groups here and now the
US retaliating specifically this evening
against the h in
Yemen okay we expect more updates from
us officials as we get them we'll bring
them here on Fox Rich Edson at the
Pentagon Rich thanks hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else